of this Thanksgiving you can have your
traditional meal or you could stop by
the golden Tiki for their annual Charlie
Brown Thanksgiving where you we're just
like the show you have a hodgepodge
holiday meal JC shows us more
Happy Thanksgiving and tomorrow night
the golden Tiki is having a celebration
A Charlie Brown Thanksgiving celebration
I'm here with Adam from The Golden Tiki
tomorrow night is going to be epic what
do you have going on buddy oh I mean
we're gonna have a a Charlie Brown
spread we're gonna have anyone that's
dressed up it's a Peppermint Patty shot
we have special drinks and a little of
food spread if anyone has seen the
special who hasn't seen the Charlie
Brown Thanksgiving special these are the
items that Charlie Brown served his
friends on Thanksgiving what do you have
so we have uh well that night we'll have
gourmet popcorn gourmet jelly beans
pretzels and of course toast if you saw
the special Woodstock the whole Snoopy
they're all making toast they have a lot
of toast to celebrate their Thanksgiving
now unlike Charlie Brown you've got
cocktails as well we've got cocktails
definitely we have a whole Thanksgiving
menu we'll have multiple cocktails
available including our CB cooler the
Charlie Brown cooler with portions go to
benefit the month of memories Center oh
that's great um and then we have a
hibiscus coconut chai tea latte a holly
holiday bird duck fat wash Negroni and
then there's there's a few others as
well and here's the thing I like to it's
on a ping pong table and the reason why
it's on the ping pong table that is what
they had and that's what they didn't in
the OG Charlie Brown Thanksgiving which
came out in 1973 by the way and here's
the thing here to come down here
tomorrow with the golden Tiki have your
Charlie Brown Celebration and remember
the special Charlie Brown and his
friends went to his grandmother's house
they still have Thanksgiving there and
then Snoopy and Woodstock all of a
sudden they pull out that turkey out of
Snoopy's doghouse and they had a
celebration so you can still celebrate
Thanksgiving with your family but come
here the golden Tiki tomorrow night with
your friends absolutely and they say the
Wednesday before Thanksgiving tomorrow
night it's like the biggest night of the
year to go out and celebrate that's a
great celebration night a great night to
imbibe and uh enjoy and be thankful
because the next day mom's cooking and
you get to sleep in you know I love it
what time does it start tomorrow night
seven to nine okay and again come
dressed up there's something from
Charlie Brown you'll get the pepper and
Patty shot from and Patty it's delicious
and if you're if you're lucky enough you
can go out back and Lucy will have that
football just like Charlie Brown did
lose another football for you to kick it
in the last second she'll pull out this
is great she was a bully yeah Lucy was a
bully but we love her anyway all right
Adam thank you very much it's the
Charlie Brown Thanksgiving celebration
happening tomorrow night at the golden